في الصين ولاول مره خارج الصالات المغلقه
مسؤول صحي يصرح باعداد الاصابات الحقيقيه
في البلاد
فبحسب المسؤول باتت الصين تسجل نصف مليون
اصابه يوميا بعد اسابيع من تخلي بكين عن
سياستها الصارمه لاحتواء الوباء
ففي مدينه السنغداو الواقعه شرقي البلاد
تحدثت وسائل اعلام محليه ان المدينه والتي
يبلغ عدد سكانها نحو عشره ملايين نسمه
تشهد بين
490.000.530,000 اصابه جديده بكرون يوميا
الى جانب انها تشهد مرحله انتشار سريع
للعدوى قبل اقترابها من الذروه ومعدل
الاصابه سيتسارع بالنسبه 10% اخرى خلال
الايام المقبله
اما في العاصمه الصينيه بكين فنالت
المستشفيات وبحسب المسؤولين نصيبا وافرا
من المرضى حيث امتلات غرف العنايه وقاعات
الانتظار بالمصابين وسط نقص حاد بتوفر
الادويه اللازمه
حصيله اول 20 يوما من شهر ديسمبر الحالي
لخصها المسؤولون حيث اصيب نحو 250 مليون
شخص او ما يعادل 18 بالمئه من السكان
بكرونا
الانفجار في عدد الحالات الى جانب اجتياح
العدوى مجددا ربما يرجع الصين الى مربعيها
الاول